JOE BIDEN’S FIRST PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN ENDED IN DISGRACE
BECAUSE HIS PLAGIARISM ISSUES
CAME TO LIGHT.
JOINING IS NOW WITH MORE IS
TRUMP CAMPAIGN NATIONAL
PRESS SECRETARY HOGAN GIDLEY.
HOGAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US HERE TONIGHT.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT JOE BIDEN’S
PLAGIARISM BUT I REALLY NEED TO
GET YOUR REACTION TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DID IN COMMUTING
ROGER STONE’S SENTENCE TODAY?
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO THAT.
WHAT’S THE PRESIDENT’S VIEW ON
THAT?
>> IT’S A GOOD MOVE BY THE
PRESIDENT COURSE.
SO MANY GOOD PEOPLE WERE CAUGHT
UP IN THIS RUSSIAN HOAX.
IT’S PERPETRATED BY OVERZEALOUS
DEMOCRATS, PARTISAN HACKS TRYING
TO TAKE ON A PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW THAT THE CAMPAIGN WAS
SPIED UPON, WIRETAPPED,
AUTHORIZED BY THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION AND WE WOULDN’T
HAVE KNOWN OF DONALD TRUMP
HADN’T BEEN ELECTED THAT CALL ME
AND CLAPPER AND BRENNAN WERE ALL
LYING IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
AND IN OTHER WAYS.
WE WOULDN’T KNOW THE NAMES
LISA PAGE AND PETER STRZOK, THE
TWO LOVERS THAT CONSPIRED TO
TAKE DOWN THE PRESIDENT WITH AN
INSURANCE POLICY.
WE WOULDN’T KNOW ANY OF THAT HAD
DONALD TRUMP NOT BEEN ELECTED.
NOW WE DO AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING BY TRYING TO WRITE SOME OF
THE WRONGS OF THE PARTISANSHIP
OF THE PAST.
>> Jason: NO, I THINK YOU’RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IMAGINE IF HILLARY CLINTON
HILLARY CLINTON HAD WON, THE
LIKES OF COMEY AND McCABE AND
PETER STRZOK, THEY WOULD BE
RUNNING THE COUNTRY AT THE
LAW-ENFORCEMENT END OF OF THIS S
THANK GOODNESS THAT DIDN’T COME
TO FRUITION.
THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING IT VERY
STRONG ACCUSATION ACCUSING
ANYBODY OF PLAGIARISM BUT IT’S
NOT NEW FOR JOE BIDEN.
HE HAS BEEN IN THIS BOAT MANY,
MANY TIMES THROUGHOUT HIS
DECADES OF SERVICE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE KNOW HE PLAGIARIZED A COUPLE
WORDS FROM THE PRESIDENT’S PAST
HE’S PLAGIARIZING THE POLICIES
FROM SOCIALISTS LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS AND AOC AND
ILHAN OMAR, RASHIDA TLAIB,
ELIZABETH WARREN.
HIS POLICIES ARE GOING TO BE SO
DETRIMENTAL TO THIS COUNTRY BUT
LET’S BE CLEAR.
WE DON’T HAVE TO GUESS WHAT I
BIDEN ECONOMY LOOKS LIKE.
WE JUST LIVED THROUGH IT FOR THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS.
850,000 JOBS WERE LOST JUST FROM
NAFTA ALONE.
70,000 MANUFACTURING PLANTS
CLOSED.
MILLIONS OF JOBS LOST BECAUSE OF
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA,
BECAUSE OF HIS DEFENSE OF CHINA.
WE ALSO DON’T HAVE TO GUESS HOW
OUR CITIES AND STREETS WOULD
LOOK IF JOE BIDEN WERE
PRESIDENT.
WE SAW RIOTERS AND LOOTERS DRAG
INNOCENT AMERICANS JUST TRYING
TO DEFEND THEIR BUSINESSES OUT
INTO THE STREETS, BEAT THEM
WITHIN AN INCH OF THEIR LIVES,
LEFT TO LIE IN A POOL OF THEIR
OWN BLOOD.
JOE BIDEN SAID NOTHING WHEN
CHURCHES WERE BURNED, WHEN
STORES WERE LOOTED, RIOTS ACROSS
OUR CITY STREETS.
HE SAID NOTHING ABOUT THAT.
SO YOU DON’T HAVE TO GUESS WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE’VE ALREADY SEEN IT HAPPEN.
I’M >> Jason: HOGAN GIDLEY,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
WE DO APPRECIATE IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY, JASON.
IF I MAY SAY ONE MORE THING.
JUST BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN’S
RECORD OF THE PAST, NOT
DEFENDING THE AMERICAN WORKER,
GUTTING THE AMERICAN MIDDLE
CLASS, I HAVE TO SAY I THINK THE
ONLY JOB THAT JOE BIDEN HAS EVER
FOUGHT FOR THAT WAS AN AMERICAN
JOB WAS FOR HUNTER BIDEN.
BUT THAT BEING SAID, I DON’T
TAKE THAT TECHNICALLY COUNTS
BECAUSE THAT WAS FOR A CHINESE
COMPANY SO EVEN STILL WITH HIS